i did not expect to cry at today's
apple announcement of one more thing
made it through the entire event
and then spoiler at the end if you
haven't watched yet and you don't want
to have a spoiler
fast forward a few seconds
oh my god i've always been there i
always will be
fast no okay
my battery's turning i gotta go plug in
good luck what
can you believe that they brought back
pc does this mean that there may be a
return
of justin long as the mac i would pay
him whatever he wanted whatever you want
you have it if i was working at apple i
would you're hired
anyway apple has officially announced
their game-changing apple silicon it's
the m1 chip
so what does this mean so with this new
chip being built in-house that means
that the intel chips that were
previously
in max will now be transitioning to
these new m1 chips which is going to
allow for even more seamless integration
between software and hardware and now
for the first time ever we will be able
to run ios and ipad apps
on the mac now this is going to be
pretty amazing because this is going to
allow us to have an even more wide range
of games and apps to choose from
this is also going to be really great
for developers because they will be able
to bring their products into even more
places so let's go over everything that
was announced today
starting with that new thing which is
the one more thing
it's basically it's it's the m1 chip
they did say that they are going to be
developing a
family of chips so this leads me to
believe
that this is just the starting point the
m1 is optimizing
for a smaller and more power efficient
mac so normally on both macs and pcs
they've used multiple chips for cpu
input output security and more but now
they're taking all of that and combining
them all into
the m1 so because all of those things
are now inside of one chip
this will allow our laptops as we know
them to become smaller thinner and
faster and with all of the new devices
that they announced today
the battery life and performance
enhancements are already
quite apparent so for those who are
curious more about the technical details
of the m1 it features an eight core cpu
with four high performance and for
high efficiency that's up to 3.5 times
faster than before
an 8 core gpu allowing for extremely
demanding tasks like multiple 4k
video streams in final cut i can hear
all of
my final cut editors cheering very
loudly in the background do you hear
them that's them that's all
they're all cheering any improvements to
make my final cut workflow faster
sign me up they've also added a 16 core
neural engine
for machine learning tasks like video
analysis voice recognition and image
processing so this will all have
a really huge performance boost so now
let's meet
the first m1 max ever first up
i would like to introduce you to the
brand new macbook air
starting at 9.99 or 8.99 for education
now this thing has no fans it's
completely silent
you can get up to 16 gigs of memory up
to a 2 terabyte solid state drive that
is
two times faster than before 5x faster
graphics 3.5 times faster cpu
up to 18 hours of battery life and a
13.3 inch
p3 wide color retina display they also
said that they were able to improve the
facetime camera quality
and it has thunderbolts and usb4
compatibility it's really crazy because
i actually remember the day that steve
jobs announced the first macbook air
and there were audible gasps in the
office that i was watching it at and
everyone was just kind of so
shocked to see him pull out this small
tiny little laptop
from that envelope that is such a huge
day in apple history
because it really was the first time
that they were kind of i was gonna say
pushing the envelope but they were
actually pulling a small laptop out of
an envelope
that really did set the bar for these
smaller portable laptops like that was
so revolutionary at the time the amount
of processing power
even though compared to what we have now
is not really that significant
but at the time it was kind of crazy to
think about how huge these announcements
are today even though some people might
not actually realize its importance
because the last time that something
this revolutionary happened for the mac
was in 2005 when they switched from
ibm's power pc chips
to intel now this is basically setting
the entire future
of apple's hardware in motion next up
they showed the new mac mini which was
really no surprise because they had
already been using these mac minis
to seed to developers with the new m1
chips since look back
during wwdc this year so all these
developers were able to start getting
their apps ready for this transition
it did change the color of them though
they now look like they're more of a
silver color instead of the matte black
from before
the starting price is 6.99 with 3x
faster cpu eight core gpu for 6x faster
graphics ethernet usb4 and thunderbolt
hdmi 2.0
and usb-a these will also have pro
display xdr support so you'll be able to
get up to 6k
full resolution and this is really great
news because those pro display xtr
displays
are expensive but they're also
incredible
and you could also buy like probably
eight and a half
mac minis for the price of a pro display
with a nano texture glass so it's up to
you
whatever you want to have a render farm
or do you want to have one mac mini with
a pro display xtr with nano texture
glass it's really
up to you the next announcement as we've
seen a bunch of rumors
kind of circulating about the
possibility of a new macbook pro
13-inch guess what we have we've got a
new macbook pro 13-inch
with the new m1 chip installed it looks
pretty similar to all of the previous
generation macbook pros
but with this new m1 chip it's much much
more powerful
2.8 times faster cpu 5x faster gpu
and apple is saying that this is the
longest battery life on a mac
yet so you'll be able to get 17 hours of
web browsing
and 20 hours of video playback so i'm
trying to like kind of combine those two
together to
do the final cut pro math like how much
battery will i have
while i'm editing a 4k video off of an
external drive
while i also have on the backlit
keyboard with wi-fi
i'm not sure i'm gonna say four five
hours maybe four or five we'll find out
we're actually we're gonna find out
we're gonna freaking test it out that's
what we're gonna do
that's my test done so those are the
three new macs that have been introduced
into the
m1 mac space but what's most exciting
about this is
the future that can only mean that the
rest of their pro lineup is going to be
even more ridiculous
i am so excited about the future of what
these new chips mean for apple hardware
and honestly like i just i really can't
wait to test these out so there's
anything specific that you guys would
like to see me test out with either one
of these devices
i would love to hear about it so leave
me a comment below and hopefully i will
be able to test it out for you if you
guys enjoyed this video give it a thumbs
up be sure to subscribe if you aren't
already and be sure to hit the bell be
notified
when i post new videos how many times
have i had to say that and
on youtube i don't know it's a lot see
you in the next one